the national Clearinghouse put out the
study released from enrollment from last
year and they found that the enrollment
was down across the board master's
degrees any program definitely down
among undergraduates but it's
significantly down among women for the
first time in a really long time which I
find interesting yeah we've known for a
while that men are declining fewer men
are enrolling in college than women but
now
just in the last year I can't say it's a
full-on trend but you saw twice as many
women didn't return to college didn't
enroll for the first time I wonder what
it is you know with like uh
Elon Musk and many others I think Peter
Thiel talked about how college is
useless is we often said or the belief
was the reason men weren't going to
school going to college was because they
were lazy or they were living in their
parents basements and things like that
I'm wondering if dudes just figured it
out yeah I think men and women are
continually under the social pressure
where they're like you've got to go to
school and get a degree so you can be a
CEO because of patriarchy and you have
to prove yourself